la consternación por los ataques sigue
latente entre los residentes de atlanta
ante el establecimiento en el que
murieron tres de las seis víctimas
asiáticas varios dejaron flores y
mensajes y reaccionaron a las
declaraciones de robert long el presunto
autor de los hechos
el triste quiero decir todo este último
año y medio solo con todo lo que sucedió
en este país desde blacklight smarter
hasta todas esas cosas que le suceden a
los asiáticos es muy triste y debe
detenerse necesitamos más seguridad
necesitamos más protección poco antes
del inicio de los tributos en honor a
las víctimas las autoridades
estadounidenses entregaron detalles
sobre el inicio de la investigación y la
reclusión del supuesto atacante que
permanece en el centro de detención de
adultos del condado de cherokee
el sospechoso se hizo responsable de los
disparos y dijo desde el principio que
no fue por motivos raciales
aparentemente tiene un problema lo que
considera una adicción al sexo y ve
estos lugares como una tentación para el
que quería eliminar
[Música]
de 21 años fue detenido durante la noche
del martes y se espera que este jueves
comparezca ante un juez por el caso que
se suma a los más de 3800 crímenes o
incidentes de odio perpetrados contra
residentes de origen asiático reportados
en el último año en territorio
estadounidense